good morning Millennials good morning
Nick Viall
good morning welcome oh I thought I got
it right thanks rod I knew it was not
even better right sometimes I knew it
was not vile sigh I put the wrong
emphasis I'm sorry welcome back to the
show happy to be back I can't look at us
we've just been doing the show for 15
minutes talking about all the pop
culture news so hopefully we have
something left to give you welcome back
we're so happy you're here this is just
evolution and its finest I know you
really really did it we follow each
other on Instagram huh I use your
essential oils I meant to tell you I
brought one of them to Utah and I really
have been enjoying them so much the
first night I use them here I slept like
a baby it's really great they're really
great and now I use them when I get out
of the shower and I have to be honest I
haven't had a migraine since you've been
on the show you heard it here first
I'm done being idle yeah I did if I may
make a promo code for all you toasters
oh good yeah promo code toasters oh yeah
30% off and it's free shipping
domestically and I highly endorse the
product I'm a big Essential Oils fan now
who knew no I'm double excited to be
here yeah I'm I can't believe I didn't
tell you that I've really been enjoying
them like I almost am through one bottle
they're great and then I guess
rollerball essential oils is that a new
thing that you cuz it's not popular
diffusers which we are launching in a
couple months but like because with with
essential oils you have to Pearson soils
is well it's there they're high in
potency so if you took a Pierson soil
and put it directly on your skin without
diluting it you could get like a rash
because it's so potent that it has those
medicinal benefits so most people
diffuse it in the air which is great we
dilute our roll odds with whole oils so
then it's safe to put on your skin so if
you don't do that you'd have to a lot of
people will do it on their own because
this whole thing I why we try to do it
for you so with diffusers are great
because you know like do you use candles
yes yeah that's terrible for you what
well think about it like inhaling smoke
right so to make a candle it's all
chemicals and perfumes and fragrances to
make it burn longer and smell good and
then you set it on fire when you burn it
into the air and you don't really see it
but that's what you're breathing and
everything again that you breathe into
your body ends up in your
organs and on your skin so instead of
doing that you can diffuse essential
oils which aren't a fire hazard isn't
smoke and have actual health medicinal
benefits so I'm saying you're spending
all that money on candles maybe get some
essential imagine all this time it's
like my candles that are killing women
every time I feel terrible I like get in
bad light a kid you know when I was in
when I was in college I was you know
like I had these these cheap candles and
you know trying to be out like I just my
girlfriend left of time and I just
thought it was cool let's put these
three candles burn right by my bed which
was just a fire had just began with
right I fell asleep and I woke up and I
went to the bathroom and like the soot
like because it like burn all through
the night so that I had soot going all
the way up my nose which is like extreme
but also that's just what like you don't
see that normally that's a conversion
but ultimately what we're all doing when
we're breathing in candles Wow okay to
reevaluate every social oils essentially
Wow and so what's your website for
you're essentially in a toils calm
natural habit on Instagram great and so
will be I will be having diffusers and
diffuser oils totally exciting anyways
thanks for plug oh my god anytime that's
what we do here uh we're so excited for
today's show because obviously you're
back we're gonna hit you with all the
news that you need to know and then
we're gonna talk about the bachelor with
now a resident expert here we've been
talking about of a little bit you have
some interesting takes already and I'm
curious to see how how we align on our
theories okay let's get to it
okay without further ado here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast we have a crunch
sound that goes then so it's like yeah
great
so could you make this I like what you
download the sound yeah make it we
downloaded the sound and so they play it
but when we do like podcast only
episodes outside of the studio we do it
with our own so we've gotten rid of it
oh yes remember on blackberry that um
when used to take a screenshot of your
thing it was like crunch munch and it
like used to bite your screen kind of
like the blackberry back in the day so
did I bring it back if only all it
really needed was a good camera that's
where iPhone had a beat because it had
everything else on it and
bbl yeah and a real keyboard the real
keyboard was nurse Kim Kardashian still
uses a blackberry she buys old ones on
eBay I'm like she lives a blackberry
life obviously she has an iPhone for her
Instagram and stuff but I think for her
business she runs off the blackberry
that's Wow
yeah it is secure though it is secure no
so makes you think anyways Nick and I
will be sharing the past five stories
and I'm excited to get your take on pop
culture first story I'm excited to get
my take I don't even know if I don't
even know I'm gonna say how up are you
on pop culture in general because you do
a podcast now does that force you to
kind of keep up more yes and no like the
podcast we try to talk about Morse more
topical things broad spectrum like we
I'll try to do some like pop culture
like but not as well as you ladies do on
a daily yeah I guess for a middle-aged
white guy I'm probably better than I
should be right better than most better
than most which is I don't know if
there's a great thing but I think being
inundated with the community that I am
like I hear it a lot yes they keep you
up fair well Pete Davidson has dressed
kate beckinsale age gap
Pete Davidson is unbothered by the way
she she is 45 and he is 25 okay wow
that's wild
and he's unbothered by the public's
opinions of his relationship with Kate
Beckinsale on this week's episode of SNL
the 25-year old comedian talked for the
first time about his romance with the
actress who was 20 years his senior
quote apparently people have a crazy
fascination with our age difference but
it doesn't really bother us he said in
The Weekend Update segment after Collin
co-star Colin Jost asked him if he'd
like to discuss his quote new situation
with the girlfriend
Davidson then jokingly pointed to the
many men in Hollywood and politics who
have debate dated much younger women
including Leonardo DiCaprio Richard Gere
Scott Disick whoever the president of
France's and Donald Trump Davidson and
Beckinsale 45 were spotted flirting at a
Golden Globes party in January mere
months after Davidson and ariana grande
called off their engagement in October
okay so he's one confirming that they're
dating too like saying that their age
difference isn't a big deal and three
why does SNL like he only comes on the
show to talk about his personal life
well Pete Anderson weirdly has become
this like pop culture phenomenon with I
mean ariana grande will definitely boost
up you're right hue rating
right right I mean he went from obscure
to like this random like search trap
yeah what a bachelor yeah but I was like
he's really talented and funny but he
always seems to be he's like the rebound
guy for other right he's like he's never
this serious boyfriend but then he's
also like the fiancee you know yeah I
don't know he's very interesting but I
think SNL offers him a level of
protection right so that's where he can
address it but still like in the vein of
like it's all fun and jokes and yeah his
peers will tease them right yes that's
what's you know comedy helps you call
yourself I like being self-deprecating
is a great way to like address an issue
and especially when you're doing it or
your friends are doing it to you and you
get less sensitive because it's scripted
and it's your friends are doing it so
there's a level of think safety there
yeah and like control you're supposed
like going in the view and then having
like whoopee being like Peter right
what's up or even opposed to going on
Twitter where it's like you only can say
so much so you say your piece and then
everyone attacks you Khloe Kardashian
yeah Twitter's like the opposite of like
objectivity right yeah but I just think
it's it's I mean it's kind of cute that
SNL protects him and gives him this
platform to like explain what's going on
his life at all times but it's weird
they're like a comedy show you would
think that they would just like ignore
it yeah at the same time I don't know
like I don't know they're all and Jos
isn't going on everybody talking about
Scarlett Johansson well it's a thing too
it's like when people ask here's the
thing I get asked about public
relationships I've been in public
relationship know being in a public
relationship like at best it's neutral
for your relationship or at worst in
like no public or being in a public
elationship doesn't help your
relationship ever
right you're not saying right there's
nothing positive that comes from it you
can survive it you can like have a great
relationship in spite of it being public
but the fact that it's public or only
bring in additional stresses having to
talk about it addresses like get
everyone's opinion about your
relationship only adds stress so it's
kind of like you know these these he's
they can't help it a little bit but
they're also like feeding into like
doing the pop shots and like
you can avoid pop shots if you want
right you know I'm sure Pete Davidson
cake back and sale know how to avoid it
right and we knew they don't then
they're okay with it and they're
inviting right and they're shocked he
gave me that's not the most amazing oh
and right so like why right yeah and it
probably isn't to protect the
relationship very fair speaking in
public relationships um were you on the
date last night
that's what when I'm the toaster spotted
you out and about I was with a friend
are you dating
sure is it hard to date cuz then the
toaster spots you out and then you got
called out is there you know you're
familiar with like reddit yeah yeah no
there are times where like sometimes on
dates sometimes I'm out with like female
friends and then I'll like have people
who read reddit I mean I've been on it
before especially we're doing research
for my podcast and it's weird to rear
it's weird to like be out and you know
the meet someone sees me out and then
they'll try to figure out who it is do I
follow him do they follow me back I -
yes
sometimes it's more I get anxiety for
the people I'm on dates but I've been
out with people or just even female
friends and they've posted like a like
they were in like a shot but like it was
their arm or something and someone
figured out who it was and they start
damning him are you dating Nick oh my
god I think it gets aggressive like
people are trying to that can be weird
that can't be weird sorry to bring it up
this is fine I but yeah I was out with a
friend it was you know a lovely friend
where did this friend see me uh
the restaurant is in that that dinner I
think I can fill it up it was a great it
was a question on uh the toast Instagram
it was a good yeah I when I go to
questions I'll see it I had a fun time
of the front that's exciting I love
having fun times with friends
okay next story speaking of fun times
with friends of the toast Jerry
O'Connell is getting a talk show test
run on Fox after subbing for Wendy
Williams Jerry O'Connell is getting a
show of his own okay I'll read this
article but they're kind of acting like
he never had a show on Bravo that was
just this you know
play-by-play do you ever watch it a few
it would have been good on it I had
a few people thank you say that do you
keep up with like Bravo and only a
little bit of reality TV a little bit
enough to be dangerous more other
peripheral no you know the players yes
I'll have a ton of friends are huge fans
I've dated people who are like huge high
school housewife fans got it and then I
you know run into a few people in LA
like Vanderpump rules people you know I
don't know them very well but I've met
them yeah they're like coworkers quote
Jerry oh great name similar to Tokyo a
new entertainment talking comedy series
hosted by the actor and TV personality
will get a three week preview this
summer her Fox stations limited run
model the series from Lionsgate dead mar
mercury and Funny or Die is set to debut
on Fox owned television stations
starting August 12th it will feature a
mix of celebrity interviews and
specially produced comedy segments from
the Funny or Die team quote we are big
believers in trying new concepts and
excited to once again be collaborating
with our friends at Fox said Mr mercury
co-presidents IRA Bernstein and Mort
Marcus quote we have come to know Jerry
as a true talent whose infectious
charisma and authenticity have made him
a favorite of many daytime talk show
fans and we are so glad to provide him
with his opportunity to shine I think
it'd be great I've met him once I once
interviewed him when I was co-hosting on
a chatter TV for people he's very
charismatic yet he's fun he's super
funny he's a really nice guy
I've when I've seen it when he was
guesting and live with Kelly I always
thought he was great I thought he mean
Ryan's great but I thought he would have
been a just a great replacement if they
would shows in him totally yeah I think
he's fantastic I think he's fantastic
I'm excited for him I feel like he he's
a great kind of host because he's like
in the industry and in the mix so he has
connections and he has insight but you
know he can also talk about it from a
distant he's really down to earth to
like I don't know him that well I mean
like say that like we're best friends
but a little bit I've seen him and run
into him he's a really down-to-earth
humble guy who hasn't lost touch of
reality for someone who's been in
Hollywood his whole whole life yeah and
has had like major opportunity yeah so
he could absolutely have every excuse to
be like completely out of touch not even
dick but delusional
yeah and he's really from what I know
not you know and I only know him on the
peripheral but everything I've seen it's
like like a soccer dad from Wisconsin
like it's great he came on the show once
and I feel like from that one experience
like I can say the exact same things
like family man excited about his wife
and his kids and like has all this cool
stuff going on in his career but like
who knows what's important and like it's
also cool about talking about all of
those things like he recognizes that
he's had all these cool self deprecating
and like nod he doesn't take himself too
seriously which it's I think it's hard
to do when you're someone you see a lot
of that for people who want it for a
season and all of a sudden you're like
Marilyn Monroe okay well here's your
team like wow like I'll let me get out
of your way sir
that's so funny and so true I'm excited
for him I still want answers on what
happened with play-by-play because like
I thought it had a lot of potential
there and they had a really good roster
I think sometimes in general with shows
you can have a great show in like even
like TV scripted show you can be
critically acclaimed and it just doesn't
get the audience you know I think
there's a it's I think having successful
shows on TV is truly hard because you
really have to have that groundswell and
you have to like reach the masses and
sometimes when you have I think a really
good show in a good format it could be
totally well done it just for whatever
reason maybe the marketing is not great
or whatever it I think it's just hard to
do because I think it's easy to do
things like have a podcast or worth a
low production but everything in TV is
such a high production value and there's
so much cost around it that you really
have to have a home run otherwise I
think they just scrap it and try
something else yeah and I so I think
that's probably why I understand it's
like scream queens did you ever watch
that show sorry all kind of wasn't it
I've heard of it it was incredible Ryan
Murphy and Emma Roberts and I was
talking about it yesterday too I just
kind of figure out a way to work it into
every episode so that maybe it'll come
back sometimes that happens I mean a
family guy was off the air
GCB you ever hear of that show no it
stood for good Christian [ __ ] it was
based on a book it was one season with
like Kristin Chenoweth and it was just
like a precious gem of a show that never
got a second season I literally should
talk about it all the time how all the
shows like I love get cancelled and now
it's got their girl room it's coming
back Restrepo and that was like that
exact
well now they just reboot everything and
everything I guess that's the formula
that works for the groundswell is like
let's go with where the people already
because they have that there's those
people who even know it didn't make it
has that great like that cult following
yeah especially great for like Arrested
Development is an amazing show and a lot
of people in like for example Austin
Powers like weird segue but like in the
theaters while Austin Powers was
considered a failure really first movie
and then it went it wasn't until into
DVD that all of a sudden people were
like wait hold on time out this is a
[ __ ] awesome show a movie and it was
because of the DVD sales that the whole
like Austin Powers 2 & 3 in the popular
the franchise came to be because in the
theaters it was considered kind of a bus
that's kind of like Riverdale too and
now with like shows that air and then
they're on Netflix like the first season
of Riverdale aired on TV I think it did
ok and then it came out on Netflix that
summer and like millions of people
watching my season 2 it was like massive
do you watch no no that's a little
alright be though oh very sad no
speaking Greek I was gonna say nine oh
two one oh also I excited about that I
wasn't allowed to watch it when I was a
kid
my parents were like those parents which
they're great parents but I also was I
was not allowed to watch but I've known
people who know Luke or knew Luke and
it's I will say when he passed like
people who know him personally were
friends with them that III know
personally
he was a great example in speaking of
like Jerry O'Connell of people who can
kind of have he was so huge and so big
but still be such a great person deep
down and humble and just the people you
want to replicate in that world I think
he was a perfect example and just to
have people I know knew him or just
truly devastated just because he was
such a great guy it's it's good to hear
those stories about people yeah
sometimes you know we live in this time
with the things like our Kelly and
Michael Jackson you hear these stories
about you have this immense popularity
and power and and then you hear these
horror stories about like what happens
when they get this power and influence
and people like Luke Perry oh really
yeah it's nice to know that there are
still some good people in Hollywood
okay next story is very exciting good
news for some friends of yours bachelor
in paradise couple Jade and Tanner tole
Baird are expecting a baby boy Claudia
joy always choked because Jade when she
met Tanner she was Jade Roper so we say
is her name
Jade Roper Tolbert or jade repair till
the air mmm
it's an interesting question sounds way
better be ready soon I can't say J and
Tanner Tolbert without it sounds better
but also pretentious right right if you
had that friend who was like hi I'm Jade
rip had to be like okay all right right
like it was cool at first but now I hate
you
Tanner Tolbert's wish has been granted
the bachelor in paradise alums shared on
Instagram Monday that he wore blue
underwear to his wife in Jade Tolbert's
gender-reveal party and quote it worked
hashtag it's a boy the Tolbert's already
the parents of a one-year-old daughter
Emerson Avery prior to Jade's pregnancy
this time around Tanner told people how
much he wanted a boy I want to have at
least one son he said last April we joke
and I tell her that she's gonna have to
keep on trying until we get that boy I I
can relate I mean in the sense that like
my whole life I've always wanted to be a
dad and like listen if I'm lucky enough
to be a dad I hope I'm lucky enough to
have a child and hopefully they're
healthy and happy but also I want a boy
right right like I just want that one
son to like and it sounds old-school but
they teach place like you know I don't
know like my I have wonderful nieces and
then my my sister had my two nephews
like when I come home I'm like I love my
nieces but like you know like I don't
know I don't know what that is like that
innate like father feeling so I can the
pressure I'm just wanting to have that
one boy and I'm suit I'm assuming if
Jade and Tanner have any more kids
whatever who yeah who cares what we have
happy and healthy but like and I'm sure
if they had another girl he wouldn't
care and love you but there's that kind
of right I'd say I wouldn't let it when
I found out that they're having a boy I
was like yeah totally it'll be great for
his gram it'll be great for his garden
there they really killed the grandma and
the parent
and that social media influence our life
there well right I'm know they do it
great but they're cheating because they
have kids it's like i joked with tanner
it's just like you have kids i have to
do stupid paintings in like dumb cooking
videos and i have to take my shirt off
just to like get a little bit of love
yeah you just bring the kid in and just
be like hey like my picture yeah and
they're like no problem
you know it's cheating it's like it is
but i guess it takes out of work it's
the culture code for it's also say like
yes i'm gonna have babies do so well
they're great content but then people
are like i don't want to see your babies
but then the likes to end up with that
with that exactly everyone's always
hating i fir i got i stirred a little
bit of a bee's nest for International
Women's Day Oh what you post up was
hilarious
most people liked it and then my and I
was all nervous at first because my well
your point
please world my strongest feminist
Friends of which I have a lot all liked
it so I was like okay I'm in I'm fine
but to your point there's always gonna
be haters or critics you can't please
the masses especially when you have a
lot of followers but to like it did very
well but then like if you read the
comments of which they're a lot most
people loved it but there's definitely
the loudest people are the ones who have
a hater so you notice those the most
because they're the loudest and then
they get in fights with other it was
International Women's Day and I had a
bunch of women fighting about a stupid
post that was and the whole idea was
like it was it's I wake up it's like
international news and I'm thinking and
truthfully it's like a personal reminder
of like well I'm alone you know like
it's like you have my followers are
primarily women so it's like oh I should
probably post something what do I post
well I mom can you send me a picture of
you like you know she's like I don't and
so that was kind of the joke of actually
being like well it would be really a
great day to have a girlfriend so the
whole idea was like I will stupidly post
a picture about me because that's all I
have to post is just me and just make a
comment about whatever and most people
got the joke but there's always some
being like way to make it about you
really really really frustrated people
yeah but yeah see people most pee
seem to get the dough it was hilarious I
appreciated it and you know it's
switching it up from the rest of the
International Women's Day content yeah
he's like the hashtag I think you're the
only shirtless male you gotta have some
fun with some things it's uh it's it's
also Instagram I mean there's an
International Day for everything right
today's it Pancake Day yeah free
pancakes not to sound corny but we
should celebrate women every day it's
not just one day an Instagram I agree
it's like it's 2019 it shouldn't have to
be a special day
right to say that we need you women in
our lives because I know I can attest
that because every day it's although
eyes like well I guess I'm just gonna
cut breakfast by myself right yeah I
totally agree great cuz I I feel like we
celebrate international men's day every
day so that when it was International
Women's Day I wasn't like clamoring to
find a picture of like all the women in
my life I feel like a post out every
single day yeah you know thank you um
also back to Jane and Tanner some news
that came out last week when Jay they
shared on YouTube that they had gotten
pregnant in paradise right before they
got engaged and then they miscarried a
few weeks later which was so sad do you
know about that
I didn't I mean I'm assuming that's
obviously a very personal and it makes
sense I think sometimes it's easier to
excuse me to just share that story after
some time has passed I you know my
sister's even my mom like you know the
women I know who have had a have had a
miscarriage in their life it can be a
very tragic or personal experience
there's a grieving process I'm sure and
so now that some time has passed
she's probably able to talk a little bit
more and freely about it with I'm sure
it still hurts but yeah a little bit
more raw back then definitely especially
because of people and their opinions and
when you share something like that who
knows what people are gonna say and if
Jay did especially Jade was experiencing
some like sensitivity about it it would
have probably been harder to you know
who knows people have been like oh you
shouldn't have gotten pregnant that
quickly right hell knows what people
said the dairyman it's still so raw like
those comments affecting where where
it's like when you're a little bit posse
of hindsight and you can let it yeah so
I didn't I didn't know I mean
yeah Jade doesn't I mean I'm friends
with Jay but I'm fine about that person
she's like you know I think that's fair
but they're great people they just moved
to LA right yeah well it's an irritating
they moved to like Orange County mm-hmm
which is like an hour and a half away
for me oh so it doesn't like count as
like they're not your neighbors well
that's much closer I get to see them a
lot more now but I kind of joke with
Tanner's why'd you move so far away
because like now yes like it's like a
whole did like come down for football
I'm like yeah though I didn't realize
that because they were living like kings
in Kansas but I haven't watched their
new YouTube video there look like I said
it's a living my kids yeah they're still
doing fine good I'm happy for them next
so he's like really crazy little
businees little travel news just
something that all travelers should know
I feel so there has been a lot of drama
with the Boeing 737 an investigation is
underway after a Boeing 737 max 8
aircraft crashed Sunday in Ethiopia
killing all 157 people on board it is
the second time in less than six months
that one of the planes has crashed
within minutes of takeoff after a new
lion Air Boeing 737 max 8 flight went
down over the Java Sea last October
killing 189 people both crashes are
under investigation and there's no
evidence of a link between the two but
similarities between the incidents have
prompted caution among some aviation
authorities and airlines
there are approximately 350 Boeing 37
737 max 8 aircraft in operation
worldwide being flown by 54 operators
according to the FAA uh so a lot of
countries are grounding these planes
including Ethiopian Airlines China
Singapore Indonesia Australia Aeromexico
came in Airways Comair East our jet
however US airlines are still flying the
bird interesting I don't know what to
make of this I'm not a travel expert but
it's always like weird when freaked
things like this happen and they can't I
just don't know what to make of the fact
that every other country is but we're
right so like the the pastry to me would
be like oh well we know what we're doing
right fine right sometimes do we like I
don't know well there are some other
international airlines that are still
find them Norwegian Airlines GUI Fiji
Airways Iceland or flydubai WestJet and
a Brazilian airline gol linhas aéreas
I mean I don't I think it's not knowing
anything about of aviation I'm guessing
that all these planes aren't bad right
so like it's a bit excessive but at the
same time is it can you ever be too
excessive when if a plane crashes
everyone dies right it could just be a
better safe than sorry
definitely want to make sure I'm not
flying a 737 and way back to LA yeah
check that I think it's it's a 737 max
eight they keep saying so I think
there's different different yeah so
maybe you're flying like an older one or
something it would be better so
technically I guess you still want to be
flying this one ah man
well you know probably maybe I never a
safer time to fly they say sometimes
unfortunately a tragedy happens
everyone's died in their eyes and
crossing their T's a little bit more but
they probably should be doing that ever
ever you've done right I don't know it's
like sometimes I feel like there's these
planes that just like take like anything
can fly nowadays you know people find
their own planes about a lot but then
it's like even just one small thing and
now people are getting sucked out of
windows it's crazy I mean also I awesome
a big believer two things people things
the world is way better play if the
world has never been better and that
will always I think be the case for at
least a while but sometimes we like in
the moment we also have so much access
to information you know in the sense
that like even 30 years ago it would the
only time we got news was on the five
o'clock news or at night or local TV but
now we're like seeing things in real
time and we're always been like
inundated with all the [ __ ] that happens
so it always it seems like more bad
things are happening because you're we
have so much information on their phone
where the 30 years ago
most of this is happening one hour a day
not even like you know once a day you
might miss it or even if it
in the newspaper and and that was only
your local news in your community not
like what was having in Ethiopia yeah
and so I think we're just we're just
bombarded with information and I think
tragic news or with it believes it leads
it's always still the case and like the
the Messier it is the more traction it
gets
and so it's like state stuff we're just
we have too much access to information
these days that is such a great point
it's not like more things are happening
we were just more aware of that actually
less things are happening yes our life
our life expenses expenses way higher
we're carrying diseases diseases yeah I
mean like we think of like all these
like documentaries have come out like
the abducted in plain sight oh my god
you got to watch that I know I wouldn't
you do I'm gonna come back I'm more
nervous I like I can't deal with like
scared like one weekend I watched
assassination of Gianni Versace and they
tried to start Ted Bundy and like I just
I felt sick to my stomach there was just
like way too much terrible things but
like the Ted but I mean apparently
abducted in plain sight is like kind of
funny or it might just messed up it's so
bizarre that you're watching it you're
like this can't be real it's sad that
it's so bizarre okay but the point of
all these is that it happened like in a
time where we just didn't talk about
things we just didn't talk about it and
so when you don't talk about it you have
less information all this [ __ ] is
happening literally in front of our
faces but we don't talk about it's a lot
of ignorance and so the world maybe felt
better because we just pretended it
wasn't happening it was all happening
right where it's happening less now cuz
we're actually more like more aware and
like being you know don't let your kids
go stranger danger and right you know
before it was like oh this wouldn't
happen like our white neighbor would
never abduct our daughter like it was a
lot of like ignorant sand a lot of just
people just pretending things didn't
happen yeah and now we're like we're
hearing all of it and it feels like more
things are happening it but also we're
just more in tune there it's probably
happening less I would it's probably
safer to have a kid now than it was but
you just hear of all these things now so
that you actually feel like this is like
the least save time have it correct but
it's probably just way better and way
that is so interesting and even with the
amount that I watched up Ted Bundy it's
like you know once he the even
technology in the way that like police
communicated between states was like not
the way that it is today like the he
would have a very hard time to getting
away with what he got away with that and
now back in the day if you into a
different state it would be like on a
different planet almost if you're like
oh well I welcome to Florida Michael yes
it was they didn't even have an ID on
your your your fifth photo wasn't even
on your driver's license Wow he was a
mass murderer who had been arrested for
killing people and Florida was like hey
welcome welcome nice tan that's so funny
and true okay and I feel better by
watching it I have a lot to watch do you
ever watch American greed it's a CNBC
show it's like each episode is like a
little documentary about like small time
or like big-time ponzi schemes in
America like I think I've seen it I just
watched an episode yesterday and I was
so interested in so I was watching
another one it's just it's crazy now it
makes you think like what is the Ponzi
scheme happening right now sometimes
things are too good to be true when they
are and I just said now I'm thinking
everything that I do like am I being
schemed yeah I mean all the time yeah I
think we all and then I was thing you
know the big one recently is fire
festival like we're covered for a minute
in terms of schemes well I think there
to your point I think there's stuff
always not gone there's probably a
serial killer out there right now just
yeah hacking people yeah you know we'll
hear about it in ten years where I will
see it on Netflix hope it's not us okay
okay fifth and final story finally the
moment we've all been waiting for hold
it under what sends final two women home
during the bachelor finale and then
there were none Colton and Irwin's 10
finalists tisha Adams and Hannah
Godwin packing during part 1 of the
bachelor season finale on Monday night
after he endured heartbreak from Cassie
Randolph in Portugal last week following
Cassie's shocking exit Colton jumped a
fence to get away from the cameras much
to the surprise of host Chris Harrison
quote I just needed to be alone Colton
says of his decision to hop away but
despite recent events Colton knows his
heart is still with Cassie quote I think
she loves me and I think she's scared I
came here for love and I found it I feel
like life without Cassie wouldn't be
complete and I feel that Cassie
completes me he explained
okay last night's episode was brutal
what did you think
I loved your tag okay so you know that I
iced and Colton and I think he's been a
very good bachelor up until this point
in all of his relationships I think he
had a really great batch of women so for
him to be right now
you know batting zero is his women were
great his women were really great and I
think I've every bachelor I always looks
at each group of women and you're like
damn they screwed me you had great girls
I love your girls they're great yeah
yeah I mean listen all in all serious no
like great women doesn't necessarily it
has nothing to do it this is all about
finding great when you were met with
right I think Cohen had great women for
us and there's an every season there's
great women yeah
but yes it seemed like they selected a
lot of women that were very compatible
and in line with the things that he was
interested in yeah I totally agree with
you yes so like at the beginning like he
really had pick up litter at the
beginning like usually I do a Bachelor
bracket and I've won like twice but um I
we didn't do one this year and I don't
even know who I would have picked away
because I thought there were so many
good options you know no it makes sense
so um for him to be in this place was
was really shocking and I understood
what he was doing but I just and but I
felt like the things that Cassie had
said to him and was saying it to the
cameras were kind of things that like
you can't come back from you know well
there's yeah I told you there's kind of
two sides to this on one side it's the
romantic notebook Nicholas Sparks like
guys chases the girl and it sounds
really like in a storybook it's like
they meet adversity and he's not gonna
give up on love and it sounds all
romantic in reality there's a hint of
hey buddy she's just not that into you
yeah and you you can't you know I know
we all want we can't have type of thing
right so there's a little kind of force
in the issue I mean Chris was like
sitting down he's like so maybe she's
just not into you like you know you can
tell Chris was trying to be nice but
also maybe being suggestive maybe being
suggestive also maybes like we're all at
home probably
so it's like what does Calton have to
say to that in that moment you know does
it's that if confronted with that issue
so yeah and then select colton and the
criticism sometimes as us guys we like
to think for the people were when
relation and he's just like i I couldn't
read people I think what about what has
happened the season suggests that she
deep down like and again in fairness to
Colton we don't know a lot of behind the
scenes in there inter moments but every
girl was like Cassie's not ready I know
her dad was like Cassie's not ready
Cassie was I'm not ready clothes like
get ready she loves me I feel for him
because like listen like you can't help
who you love I think back if I was in
that position and Vanessa had left at
that time I would probably a similar
action and it doesn't like in all
fairness to Colton like he definitely
screwed over Hannah G and Tasha but
Lee's also just following his heart like
that says who he has feelings for right
and you what he's easy is supposed to
get engaged at energy because he thinks
she's really pretty and they have a nice
time yeah like that's not what you're
getting right he's doing like the
difficult thing because it's right for
him so I don't actually don't even fall
Colton aside from like the fact like men
always want what they can't have blah
blah blah I'm just like I'm really upset
with Cassie for the way that one that
she handled things and two it's like you
came on the show and I think most the or
viewers of this show you know we have
like the you know we're not totally
naive like you go on the show yes you're
gonna be on television yes you're gonna
get Instagram followers and all that's
really exciting and it seems like like
her backing out at this point it's like
she got what she came for and she was
never interested in Colton and now she
has to get out of it as quickly as she
can before she takes it before it gets
too far gone and like it's too far gone
totally i here's i'm really curious
about tonight because last night colton
seemed happy and he talks about casting
his relationship as if they're together
and hannah g said twice I'm very happy
for you
meaning that there's a hatch there's I
mean if Kat and if Cassie and Colton
aren't either engaged now or dating or
whatever and we'll find out tonight I
will be shocked I would be she right so
there let's assume they're dating so I'm
fascinated by this because last night
when you after can't you know there'd
like this Colton's like I'm gonna chase
he's telling everyone I'm gonna go after
the girl meanwhile they cut to kasi
after she breaks up a cult and like you
can she's like relieved I'm confident in
my decision I'm happy to get home into
my family I'm happy to move on with my
life this is not like the what did I
just do like I don't know like I
panicked this is I do the right very
poised and whatever and the episode ends
with Colton knocking on we're assuming
Cassie's dorm right so here's Cassie her
dad comes in and ultimately saves her
and I thought her dad was great am i
saving her it's like I do empathize with
Cassie in a sentence because it listened
forever all parties it's just a
difficult position to be in
you don't know what it's like you can
know the idea but there is a lot of
pressure of the accusations that gets
thrown around it's not a crime for
Cassie to go on The Bachelor
thinking Colton's attractive too like
Colton and it get to the point and to
say I don't love that's not a crime to
not have feelings for The Bachelor right
and so for Cassie to bow out is just as
Noble as Colton like Cass : doesn't get
any more credit than Cassie for doing
the right thing especially when Cassie
is at the risk of a lot of chrism
Cassie's at the risk of all the girls
saying I see I told you I told you and
the fear of proving everyone right and
then Colton knocks on her door and I'm
really curious because now Allison
Colton comes in Cassie thinks like she's
done right she's going home and then
Colton knocks on door with a bunch of
cameras that walk in and say hey I know
I thought you were done but just so you
know I dumped everyone else I ended the
show I want to date you here's a bunch
of cameras and Colton like so now what
right what are you depressed like now
cassie is back to square one and her dad
can't save her anymore and I'm curious
how genuine is this relationship if like
and I feel for Cassie I feel for Colton
because like there's so many variables
other than two people in the privacy of
their home having this like break up but
I want to get back together and making
it a citizen just based off your their
feelings is impossible because : walks
in with a bunch of cameras
and the news of I dumped it everyone
else right she feels like but based on
what she said what she said a lot of
things but I think her main thesis was
that like she knows closing months of
being aged she knows she she knows she
can't get there she doesn't want to stop
him from having that happy ending so
she's removing herself from the
situation because she doesn't love him
enough to be in that place but like he's
removing all of that pressure he's
ruined the other girls he's definitely
not gonna propose to her so like it's
just me and you and you know starting
tomorrow we'll be alone off the show is
that what you want is that what you
think though because sometimes in
relationships you know every time
someone breaks up with someone and you
care about them you don't want to be a
dick or a [ __ ] or whatever you want you
want to be nice and so you sometimes at
the risk of hurting their feelings you
sugarcoat the truth though cassie is she
even because of being in batch world is
I can't get ready for this I can't get
engaged you know all these things you
said but Colton was when she was
breaking up with him saying great don't
like everything she was saying he was
like no problem oh no problem oh and she
still broke up with him right right so
that means there's more there's more and
the more is I like you I you're not
might like you don't all the things
Cassie dad was saying this is how I want
you to feel and I know a lot of people
are like well I've you know I didn't
feel this certain way and I came around
but like I think Cassie you could tell
deep down there isn't this spark and
what I've always said is in that world
if you feel anything for anyone
you will feel everything for them that
world is meant to make you think you are
over the moon with someone even though
if you just like them so yeah Cassie to
be so pragmatic and so level-headed and
so unsure about her feelings which
suggests to me outside of that world I
don't know
and I really feel for both of them
because I give Colton credit for
following his heart and I've Colton
Cassie credit for like me leaving but I
don't know like yeah I'm more fascinated
about the pressure that of what Cassie's
gonna feel when Colton knocks on her
door the bunch of cameras and then drops
his bomb of like I oh yeah by the way
Cassie is like all you're letting you
date other people by leaving in cones
like knob I literally ended the show and
this is imagine what Cassie would look
like
if Colton knocks on the door says I
broke up with anyone everyone else in
kasi it was like now that would be
imagine that pressure even a moment
Cassie's thinking like what should I do
right I like Colton and sometimes we can
convince people Vic you know what he's a
good enough guys and treat me right okay
and we're just gonna date anybody I
don't get engaged if it doesn't work out
right it's it's a lot of pressure but
it's also kind of no pressure like I
have to do is say yes right now and then
we'll fly out front it's kind of
fascinating too but at the same time I I
like we are dealing with a bunch of
people who are younger and not that like
you can't get married or engaged when
you're 23 but it's especially they can
cast his world like beautiful girl young
sky's the limit of what Cassie right she
seems to be aware of what a million
followers yeah but you from forget about
that she seems aware of her pot even if
it weren't for the Bachelorette right
yeah here's someone who has the world's
her oyster so to like decide in nine
weeks whether Colton's the rest of her
life is a lot of pressure on anyone
especially someone who feels is that she
has the limitless opportunity I
understand that and yes so I there's no
one that I'm really faulting here I just
wish like it's frustrating not to get
that happy ending totally well that's
kind of on I mean we all knew that was a
risk going in yeah
and that was it like and you were right
you know Colton like what's cold never
really ready to get engaged where half
of the women who showed up ever really
ready to get engaged maybe not you know
yeah and that's sometimes a risk of
casting a younger group right right all
right
yeah but it's all fast and it's been fun
to watch it has been fun to watch and
like this season really did not
disappoint an offense Jim did not
disappoint like it's been teased all
season everyone's been excited yeah
really it really is really compelling I
wanted to like Colton to jump out of the
bushes and cuz like they're like well he
could be he could be anywhere you could
be in the bushes it was like would you
really think he's sneaking in the bushes
like do you really think Colton standing
behind a tree like come on right unless
you like if you really don't want to be
found he could have hit and
wouldn't have found him well I mean it
was a little bit of at the same time it
was super dramatic but I guess it what
was Colton gonna do like I get quitting
the show but I don't understand like
running away from production right Thank
You frickin that was a little bit like
alright buddy like know so I'm glad he
was just walking like he was just
blowing off steam yeah that was fine it
was he was like pissed and he was it
felt like he was pissed at the show you
know my guess is here's why is because
it was Cassie's dad and not that he was
mad at that but Colton also doesn't know
what's going on either
so when Cassie tells Colton well my dad
showed up
I mean Cole's on it like I'm sure that
was all organic and genuine within the
confines of the show but Cassie's dad
can't show up unless the show that's it
right right so when she when Cassie's
hearing when Colton's hearing that from
Cassie immediately Colton's thinking
will they let this happen
and so whether it's in like he's it's
easy to blame the show write it easy for
Colton to get mad at the show and
there's some responsibility but the show
should let Cassie's dad come I mean they
should have more of that they should
have fathers who want to come and give
their daughter extra moment a pause also
he could have came for giving Colton the
blessing he didn't give at hometowns
Yeah right like if he came in Cassie was
like no this is it I love him he might
have got him in like and I always said
the producers they don't they don't
script things they create situations and
they're very good at adapting and so
when Cassie's daddy wants to come
they're like great let's film it let's
see what happens we don't they don't
know what's gonna happen yeah they
didn't even know what was gonna happen
when I guarantee you Cassie went into
that day's telling him producers that
she's probably to break up with him
but they also probably assume that Colt
would fight for her and from that point
they don't know what's gonna happen
it probably had a fantasy suite room all
set up and they also have a van ready to
go in case he goes huh a Cassie goes
home that's what they do they're ready
for everything and they let things play
out and that's part of their job as
producers to invite situations that are
gonna create interesting outcomes and so
I get like Colin's upset but the show
does nothing wrong for letting it yeah
that's fact that he was definitely i
guarante de Casas de I was him being mad
at
for sure for sure okay so switching
gears a little bit we're gonna find out
who the Bachelorette is tonight do you
know like I think I know who it is
we suspect it's Hannah be we suspect
it's hella believe what do you think I'm
not here for it
you weren't here for me I wasn't here
for you so that's true tell me why
because first of all I think there's a
lot of good options so like it's I would
like to evaluate everyone and now we
have two new options Taoiseach and
Hannah Jane sure that we didn't have
yesterday when we were all right so what
about why why wouldn't Hannah gee maybe
be your choice well I don't know if she
would be my choice I don't know if she
can helm a so um but I thought after
last night I had more faith in her than
I did before that she was really I'm
sorry for trouble oh no go ahead I see
that she was articulate and explaining
her feelings I think she really does
want to fall in love and she was able to
like just communicate how she was
feeling in a way that's not full of
cliches which i think is important
totally I definitely believe that she
was heartbroken but it also seemed a
little like she's clearly not a person
who emotes a lot and you and that gets a
little boring and even when you you
definitely believed Hannah's heartbreak
but it also came across as like come on
a little bit more and a little bit more
like yeah you know she was so collected
and calm and I think she values that it
would I think that's an important thing
to value but it's not interesting TV for
an entire season but keep in mind that
people always forget right it's one
thing to be a fan favorite on the
bachelor/bachelorette and be top three
or four because in top three or four
gets limited air time especially like
three or four you only see their best
moments and they're gonna be the fan
favorites because a little bit of
protection now you're carrying an entire
show right now you're in every scene
you're in every conversation you better
be interesting no and like a they turn
you know I remember even like Jo Jo was
a fan favorite on Ben's season and then
she becomes the Bachelorette and it's
just like everything she does you're
just gonna pick apart because what else
you gonna every lead gets heat no matter
who you are Ben got heat for saying I
love you to two women you know I got
heat for breaking up of a bunch of girls
on dates because I was like I'm trying
you know
Colton gets heat for you know not being
ready like every every lead you know
Kaitlyn got heat you know it
because your every decision is being
criticized yeah I can't make there's
just it's a winless battle so in a
Kaelin I think what okay Lynwood there's
okay I actually I never really took
figured out whose side I'm on in the
Kaelin hanabi pageant fight you know we
never really got an outcome as to like
what what happened they keep talking
about it but I still don't know what
happened maybe they're just not like for
each other and I think like Kaelin was
definitely giving me more villany vibes
then Kailyn she has a little there's
something villainous about her but then
when confronted and like I thought she
handled herself so well at women tell
all
I think everything that they said that
she said she had a good explanation for
and like I personally don't think it's a
negative thing or even that awful for
the girls to be talking about who's
gonna be Bachelorette I think that is a
normal conversation and I think that was
something I came up on Annie season when
the guys were talking about who's gonna
be the match or like yeah I mean you
everyone knows what they've signed up
for like only one person can win and yes
one person will be the bachelor and
almost always in those situations it's a
passing comment that someone who's
looking for you to say it's nothing big
oh I heard bachelor or bachelorette come
out of their mouths like it's right know
you're here to be that truly that dumb
to show up if they hey guys I really am
here to be the bachelor right like no
one says that so I thought she didn't
lie or say she never said it she had it
like a perfectly good explanation I
think that she's there's a lot to her I
don't know if I would luck there's
something a little bit unlikable about
her so I don't know if she'd be a great
Bachelorette but like I wouldn't count
her out and there's something about
Hanabi and she's just so sweet and
positive and cute that's like annoying
gonna be Hanabi
so these are all great tags but here's
why I love okay
choice it's because I think the henna
G's in the Kalin's I think Taoiseach
would be good I agree cuz she's like an
outlier she's not she's differently
different than even personality I mean
obviously she's you know mixed so like
there's that yeah but Kaylin and Hannah
G are so poised they're so thoughtful
everything I mean it's everything that
comes out of their mouth you can tell
they've thought it through
and again after overtime that's this it
also not only is boring but it it is a
little insincere there's no way because
to your to your point there's there's
more with Kalin and I bet and that not
that this is a negative thing I bet she
can be [ __ ] sometimes I like that she
can be super Savage that's interesting
but she'll never show that right as soon
as she did when when that girl was
talking about her forgot who was talking
[ __ ] and she was like that stupid [ __ ]
I'm gonna call her out it's like yes
that makes her more like she's the
pageant queen who's never gonna show
that she's poised and I just don't find
that particularly interesting as a
bachelorette Hannah B on the other hand
it's clearly a person if she thinks it
she says it and it's gonna be likeable
and it's gonna be unlikable and it's
gonna be interesting and she emotes and
I think that's interesting you know what
you make a very good point it's like she
sometimes she's saying something and I'm
like that's really cute and sometimes
she's saying something I'm like cringe
she can't make a toast yeah but in she
made her toes and then she like added
roll tide I thought that was hilarious I
think that's great I think Taoiseach is
summoned because she's older and she's
been divorced and she's a has more
perspective and a little bit more
maturity just by definition of her life
I think just then she would be more real
to big as anyone who has more maturity
and comfortable skin and their skin is
is willing to like I think speak a
little bit more freely and real and I
think she would be good in that sense
too because she's been through more life
and I think that would be an interesting
element - I agree she should bring some
gravitas however after her breakup last
night and her horrible acting skills I
don't know if she could break up with 25
men kind of I also I think I said this
on my podcast and this is not like
someone in like every every season
whoever's it's it's always a two-person
race for the most part right so when
you're three or four not that there's
not a connection you definitely have a
vibe with the lead but you both kind of
know yeah you both kind of know it's
like yeah we like each other that was
clear with them I'm so like as soon as
Colton shows up she knows she knew she
was getting dumped because we put our
shoes on yeah like oh it's time I'm
ready to go a little earlier than I
expected but you know what I can
navigate Thank You PAC I could do this
because like
morning of like colds like we had fun in
Taoiseach I was like yeah we didn't do
anything what she knew yeah and so she's
at this point like alright how do i
Colton
it's fine you know I'm gonna be the
caregiver and again that's not a rip on
Taoiseach like she just she knew she was
going home right so like Hannity and the
other hand absolutely did not absolutely
she was the Blake in the mean when I
would like the person who absolutely was
like there's always two people usually
who are like I'm the one yeah I'm the
one and the three or four is like
everyone knows like it slows to it's one
I don't know who it is but it's one of
those two yeah and I think Taoiseach was
she knew yeah she knew so I just I don't
know if she liked the acting wasn't
there for me but she also didn't feel it
so it'd be curious how would she be she
shouldn't be breaking up with people all
the time and she's not gonna be feeling
it but like I can't watch her break up
with her third person like that again
you know that's a good point I think I
think gonna be you're honestly you're
really convincing me and she thought was
Claudia so Claudia that has her seal of
approval oh you know if it was that easy
I would have like I'm realizing like
that's the thing I tell you who I love
and like in another world I know it
would never happen but I could I could
stand for to watch her on TV for 12
weeks
Demi well you heard it
Demi is on my podcast tomorrow yeah like
did you filming already we did is she
amazing have a champers I will say
there's a couple things you should watch
it I'm going to I was a little nervous
to have Demi on like my podcast you know
Demi's younger and Demi was the Spitfire
who kind of had a bit of a reckless
mouth at times and my podcast at this
point has been you know women who I'm
like I'll ask a lot of questions and
about like I'll share my opinion but
I'll get theirs and they'll share some
perspective about the career Demi is a
little bit different it was more of a
bachelor kind of interview yeah so I
wasn't sure how it would go it had no
rapport with Demi but I thought she was
interesting a good watch and she's fun
so I'm like I'll have her on and you
know Mikey talked to her after you saw
women tell all our before after and so a
lot of the episodes the heads up but I
kind of tease
a little bit because I wanted a I think
Demi is great I think she's a lot of
potential so it was a lot of me like
kind of like asking her about the
Cougars and teasing a little bit but
I'll say this
I'll Demi had a lot of comparisons to
Kernan I know you love Korean but
Corinne I think burned out a little bit
I think Korean got a little too caught
up in her own on the show whereas
tradition high and I don't think Korean
was good at necessarily showing humility
I think a lot of people liked that
Corinne was like I'm unapologetic myself
but Demi was really humble and really
nice and just friendly and she was
self-aware in the sense that she took
the piss out of herself and we talked a
lot about that you see a softer side of
Demi and I'll tell you what we do Q&A
and give advice to fans at the end she
gave some really great advice too and I
honestly didn't know what to think like
what are we gonna hear from Demi Moore
I'm giving advice and I was like Demi
gives her advice if a kid don't listen
her it wasn't that she gave some really
great perspective and so I left with a
better impression of Demi not that I had
a bad one then I then then before I
think she she was really cool and I
think I think she's gonna do great
things on paradise I think she's gonna
do great things on paradise as well but
like I was impressed I was a I think
she's so interesting you never know
what's gonna come out of her mouth which
I just enjoy from someone on television
anyway I did enjoy like whether I agree
with them or disagree with them it's
just nice that it's not I know it's not
gonna be you complete me I love you know
she's authentic that way and again
having been in that world sometimes
people say things because and Demi
talked about that she kind of admits to
like yeah I said this because I thought
this and I said you don't need to do
that you are already interesting so just
say what you think don't say what you
think people want you to say there's a
difference because one will give you
longevity and make you really
interesting over time and the other will
it will be a stick and it will get old
and you'll you'll get yourself in
trouble anyways I thought I thought demo
is fantastic and I hope people I'm
excited to see more from her and I will
listen because and I do think she would
have been fantastic Bachelorette for the
same reasons I think Hannah B will be
great
okay I you know what you've really
turned me we'll find out tonight I think
that it will be hunt you they really do
pick up until the last minute like no it
always it could be changing right
it honestly it truly could Kennedy might
have gotten amazing responded percent
that is possible that has happened in
the past they're really good at adapting
but so never you know it's never it's
never confirmed yeah also I saw on
Twitter last night I wanted to ask you
Caitlyn's tweet live tweeting the show
and she said that she also had tried to
quit during her season but production
wouldn't let her that she tried to you
know pull occult and jump offense did
that are you aware of this and and when
would that have happened I I don't know
I wasn't aware I think probably the
truth more is is that I think every lead
has that moment and again I guess a like
had Vanessa left
I know Caitlin went through a lot when
it came to Shahnameh Caitlin bloke a lot
of rules and Caitlin did a lot of things
to get herself in trouble and that
created you know I think I think
sometimes Caitlin leaves that out of
like she did a lot of things behind the
scenes with me and with Shawn that she
wasn't supposed to do which in some ways
you could praise her for like keeping it
real right but also people sometimes
forget this is a show and and while we
appreciate like Colton's authenticity
it's still a show that we all signed up
for there are well now I know there's
people with jobs and audio and camera
people Colton leavin leaving screwed
people over in terms of like their meal
their paycheck yeah I know I'm only
saying that is that there's a reason why
some of the times these rules are in
place for leads and a cast member to
foul because if you break the rules it
becomes very messy and it screws up the
integrity of the show but in Kaitlyn's
fairness being the lead I always is
truly an impossible task and it's very
hard and to get through it feels
impossible so every lead handles it
differently and everyone at some point
in the season filming like regrets it's
like I why did I I should never have
done this it's just you it's such an
impossible task so I'm sure can't let
felt like that at times for sure
definitely I mean and you can it really
is like an impossible choice so at best
like you just have to feel good about
the decision that you're making because
you end with love and maybe like
you know your Q score is lowered yeah
I have questions for you from the people
but one more thing I want to talk about
that was a big topic of conversation
last night was Colton's hair wow oh my
god it made me so sad because at first
when I saw his hair and honestly it took
me ten minutes cuz I really wasn't
looking at him because T she looked so
beautiful she looked very nice she hurt
Hanna G really stepped it up you know
like revolve will be calling right
always right they'll be revolving around
the world I can't wait to see them at
Coachella um so I noticed Colton's hair
and like he was really looking like you
know a Backstreet Boy and it was
shocking and I said something on my
Instagram I was like hey or question
mark and then when Chris Harrison
brought it up because everyone on
Twitter was talking about it which like
I felt really sorry for him like he was
already having a rough night and then
like you could just see like his
confidence was low and what what do you
think happened there
I don't we all get it like we're
especially at that point we're all a
little sensitive cones a sensitive guy
right but Colton and I do too so this is
not necessarily knocking :
Colton cares about how he looks and what
people think he you know he's he glams
up a little bit you know his hair keeps
changing
he has since straighten his hair these
are all fine things it's also just tough
in the bachelor world because you know
people are looking to criticize it's
part people watch it to snark right a
bachelor world is not the world to make
strong fashion choices or hair choices
you know for all the like I you know my
wore the turtleneck which like was you
know my style as month of Bachelor and
put it on so all this is coming in I'm
like I feel like this is a little too
bachelor world you know and I kind of
joked with you before the show we're not
rock stars we're not actors in that
world and so when you're a rock star or
an actor you're like you're an artist
and so you come out to the red carpet
wearing this like crazy out for this new
hairdo everyone's like oh gosh in what
fashion what an artist what a brave oh I
want to do that and bachelor that's the
opposite it's like ha ha ha like it's
yet yeah his hair was a little spiky
it's just not the time to make brave
choices and said Colin's mistake was his
hair look fine whatever right it just
wasn't the time to take any you should
have just gone super neutral or even you
could have done it tonight where
hopefully it'll be a more redemptive
episode like a by talking hair right
like I got through night one
like last night was as bad as it's gonna
get for him like from the show like you
know in terms of people just hating on
him and then he also did the hair on top
of it like if you did it tonight we
wouldn't even notice because it's all
happy it's poorly tonality
I'm clearly not the issue I wouldn't go
I don't think it's his best look yeah no
I like his hair just like normal you
don't straighten that but it wasn't like
he didn't come out with dreads right
shave his head really it wasn't that
crazy got a little nuts with the gel
okay now I have some questions for you
before I let you go but you know we're
running over and I know you're a busy
man so I'll make it quick one do you
think that you could have cleared that
fence no yeah I would I would like to
have tried I'm a pretty athletic guy not
this maybe when I was called me old age
okay because that was called the age I
could have done it actually the only
thing that would have been funnier than
her me jumping the fence was like him
attempting to income taxes going up and
just faceplant but on my season The
Bachelor absolutely not okay fair which
if any of the girls on his season would
you consider going on a date with anyone
you know last night for example like you
know I was like I I don't I'm not even
bother live-tweeting when it was a
beginning the episode when Colton's like
hiding in before and I tweeted something
meanwhile Hanna gee with a girl blonde
emoji hand up my tweet was this like
meanwhile Hanna G's waiting for Colton
over here and then course Twitter's like
oh my god Nick trying to see yeah well
it's like first of all I'm not a blonde
chick you know waving and I only said it
because like listen I had I had Demi on
and Demi was great and she was
flirtatious and fun but when it comes to
bachelor nation
I am I mean I've had girls DM me and I'm
honestly I've been like listen like you
seem great I look forward to meeting you
but when it comes to bachelor nation I
just stay away I would have to truly
meet someone where I'm like you could be
the one and I'd really have to risk
because I just I'm not looking for that
type of gossip or whatever and I'm not
looking to casually date anyone who's
been on The Bachelor so I just really it
would have to be I already try to stay
away from it but I think only has a lot
of great women and I
for to meeting them and they're very
beautiful and interesting and but
there's no one who's like oh I have to
meet her because I think I could date
her and I'm I just kind of stay away
from it
fair um question for me you weren't
there last night when they brought out
some old bachelors and mostly
contestants to get to share advice where
you asked to be there where you want
able I was yeah well I wanted to be here
instead no they asked me to be part of
the live show I think they'll be
bringing some people they'll bring some
people back I don't know if they were
going to have me on last night or
tonight but I was like now I'm doing the
morning toast yeah so you say that every
bachelor has had like this fence jumping
moment where they're like frustrated
with the show and they would like to get
out for you if you had that moment when
would it have been well I was I was
lucky in the sense that it would have
been ahead Vanessa left during that time
right I think you know it's depend it's
hard regardless I definitely every
bachelor or bachelorette goes in in
their first fear is will I like anyone
will I really fall for anyone because
what happens if I doubt there's d/s
expectation yeah and then once you do
start to connect someone your second
fear is well what if they don't like me
right so I spent most of time being
afraid of of that thankfully it seemed
like Vanessa did but there was always a
stress and then like you know Rachel and
Vanessa didn't really get along we all
kind of knew that I was kind of wigged
out about that I really liked Rachel I
really liked Vanessa and especially with
Rachel even though I didn't like vibe
with her on that I really respected
Rachel and I really valued her opinion
right so it really it really bugged me
that she wasn't getting along with
someone I was falling for right and so I
was there were some moments or the end
where I was like it I had this fear of
okay in my heart I knew I was gonna do
but is this all gonna fall on my face
unfortunately it's like what Colton's
healing because it's like they're saying
all these things at the girl then yeah
it's a scary feeling because again you
like Colton laughs not you can't you
can't help how you feel Colin's not
supposed to get engaged at energy just
because she likes him the most right
right and so
it's a tough situation so I never got to
that point but that's what it would have
happened got it okay how awkward is it
to face all the girls that you broke up
with
and what's more awkward women tell all
or after the final rose
it's a great question that's tough art
was my own question it's definitely
harder to be the bachelor of The
Bachelor no sense because like every
every tell all the guys you know don't
want to it's they're like you were great
that sure ed or whatever like they just
want to see gentlemanly and nice and you
know even like Chris Harrison will tease
it like you have to face all your
ex-girlfriends and like right when
everyone's auditioning for paradise so
it's like you can be the most sad most
the most annoying part is every app is
every tell all it's always the people
you barely remember those name who are
on two weeks and they're just chirping
at you they don't you don't even they
don't air a lot of it you're just kind
of like you're trying to smile and put
on a good face because you don't wanna
seem like a dick but you're just kind of
like annoyed because it's like you don't
care right we don't you didn't connect
you're mad I sent you home and now
you're auditioning for paradise right
and I had to be honest as a viewer it's
we can sniff it out as well and it's
really annoying to hear from people that
like are irrelevant that are just like
thirsty
I think tell more things can change
drastically I'm sorry after the final
rose
you know yeah moments can happen the REM
Beca situation you know when I made the
mistake of calling out Andy even last
night like I think I don't think
anything traumatic happened last night
with energy but it could have something
where all of a sudden was like this
groundswell of reaction so you can have
a lasting effect at and so with Raven it
was like you know I didn't know what she
was going to say and and just trying to
like be gentlemanly but like it's a
tough position to be because do you do
you just smile but then like seem
disconnected because like why are you
smiling I'm pouring my heart out why do
you look look defensive it's it's hard
to do and it's live so you don't have
the the benefit of an edit to like you
set the camera on you yeah you could
have like a twitch in your face and
you're like rub it you're like oh you
know like no that seems weird you know
I actually didn't watch you after the
fact you are
bachelor after the final rose because we
were in Israel at the time so I don't
even remember like the dynamics but I
feel like also sometimes it's like
you're talking to your ex like this
number two while number one is in the
back room and it's like even things that
you might say to her that you would feel
comfortable like what they like yes
right and I felt that way last night
between Hannah G and Colton every lead
is worried about what they say it's like
I don't want to be a dick but if I'm too
nice I'm gonna have to deal with this
later later and that's a tough it's yes
very much so
rikes I feel like Colton wanted to say
it's like yes I was when I was with
other girls I was thinking about Cassie
but you weren't one of those girls also
can we just again in the future for guys
or girls when you're breaking up with
someone I know you want to be nice but
don't remind them of the nice things
that you used to say when you like them
you still remind me of home really
potent [ __ ] you well you know I mean wow
and I know he was just trying to be nice
but like not the move buddy like oh I
was like oh no and I'm glad Hannah G
called them out yeah for that and again
nothing against like we've all done that
we've all made those mistakes but don't
do it no we're like he opened starts
every breakup was like just the nicest
things and actually sounds like he's
about to propose it's really mean yeah
it's confusing or like when Taoiseach
comes out and like he's there and he
smiles like yeah like washing it back
was like I'm sure therapeutic for you
it's like really suck yeah I can't like
sometimes some of the girls who like
aren't really so invested in it they
love to say like you know watching back
I totally saw that it wasn't me and it's
a nice cop-out for both of them totally
but Hanna G was not having it no because
Hanna G had real feelings yeah like
Blake had real feelings for Becca yeah
you know there's there's only it's in
it's always a two-person race yeah okay
before I let you go just one question
that's like a little juicy are there any
bachelor nation like hookups that we
don't know about Laura or do these
hookups like happen all the time oh I'm
I'm sure there are those who don't know
about I don't I don't there's not like a
mass group tax everyone be like hey I
just [ __ ] so-and-so like that is there a
mass group text like from seasons oh
there's always a Matt like every season
there's like there's every season
there's two group texts
right there's the math group text which
is started by all the early people who
leave they're always the most bitter
right they get on it's like the first
two all the first these women who go or
guys go in first week three and they
like connect and they're gossiping all
the things and it's always and it's
always especially shit-talk like it went
it's the batch it's always a oh he's not
that great he's gonna look terrible I
never really liked him anyways there's a
lot of that and then every time people
get have to show their they get added to
this list and there's this group text
and then there's like the final four
group text yeah where if you're in the
final four you feel and because you did
you have had a very different experience
than everyone else and everyone else and
this other group tax thinks they've had
the same experience as you did as a
final four and you're like you did it so
usually there are these two group texts
it's like it's like being fourth place
at the Olympics you know it's like
there's the people who medal and then
there's yeah and it's just a different
experience and so a lot of people in the
big group text are trying to relate and
they want to know and they get the COS
pits and gossip and all like the things
that like for example reality Steve gets
there always from people who go home the
first three weeks who are hearing things
on the peripheral every season would be
my guess I mean that's a I wonder but I
mean it's camp there's a lot of people
who work and are on that show so like
yeah there's immune that's the thing
there's sound guys there's there's
hundreds of people who have girlfriends
and boyfriends and there's a lot of
people who can talk but every season
there's always a few people on the
season who are a little bitter and a
little man that didn't go very far and
they hear all the gossip from these
group texts and they kind of just tell
everyone so interesting well thank you
so much for joining us sorry I kept you
over but it's just so much to break down
and now I feel really good going into
tonight whatever happens I feel like I'd
be falling I've we've worked through all
different scenarios yeah you know they
there may not be a wedding or kids but
it's fun that's fine because by then
also they don't even really do TV
weddings anymore so it's like whether
you get engaged or just dating like it's
the same time I ask you want to request
me before you leave
what do you think about Cassie being in
another reality TV show while
concurrently running okay so I saw it
and I really like I wasn't until I saw
it like for the eighth time that I was
okay maybe I'll like look into it and it
was just like a student project like
fake show I mean I don't think that it
like means that she's like so thirsty
and just here to be on TV um I mean it's
not like the best look for her but I
didn't think it was such a big deal like
and also you know people who on The
Bachelor are comfortable and wanting to
be on TV so makes sense that she tried
something else once and it was like you
know Christian College siesta key maybe
I should watch it like just to get to
know her better but yeah I don't know
what did you think kind of agree with
you yes curious yeah it wasn't a
deal-breaker for me okay thank you so
much for trailer this is so exciting
Claudia will be on tour like forever so
maybe if you were back in New York we
can do this again thanks for having me
and hey 0 to 100 look where we've come
anything can happen a true life
no and you and you we're the one who
started with your maturity or maybe you
just didn't know all the things that we
had said about you but we but we really
you've helped us really grow up and
mature and evolve so thank you for that
no I just I'm just happy we're all right
thank you thank you for these essential
oils and thank you for your expertise
and your time where can I run follow you
Nick my all on Instagram bio files check
us out tomorrow we'll have Demi on so
it's a podcast is it a video podcast
much like this it's it is you can check
us on a youtube so you can watch it if
you want and it's also on Spotify and
you stitch her in iTunes and every place
you would find or listen to a podcast
and you can watch us on YouTube much
like this show perfect so you guys
already accustomed to it we will see you
tomorrow we have an amazing guest
tomorrow countess Lemann will be in
studio and we're shook to the
[ __ ] core so see you then
Claudia will be back have a great day
everyone
you